Candy Truth.
Hello everybody. Welcome back. Tonight
we are going to cover the long awaited
topic of spectator sports and it's quite
involved more than I ever thought. Let's
find out what the history is of
spectator sports. So what I'm reading is
a bunch of different sources and and
paraphrase quotations from different
sources. This one says, "In ancient
Greece, the Olympic Games was founded in
BCE. They were central to Greek pagan
culture and held in honor of Zeus. These
games were a form of worship involving
physical contests such as wrestling,
javelin throwing, and chariot racing.
These events reflected the belief that
physical excellence was a way to glorify
the gods and maintain divine favor.
That's written by sport and spectacle in
the ancient world um wy blackly
publishing. So if you take this idea,
please hold on to that as we go forward
to understand things a little deeper.
Then as we cover ancient Rome, it says
Roman spectacles, including
gladiatorial combat, chariot races, and
theatrical performances. Now they're
adding theater with
it, were equally tied to pagan
rituals. The Colosseum and Circus
Maximus were arenas for grand public
displays that celebrated Rome's gods and
imperial power. These events were not
mere entertainment but had spiritual and
social significance reinforcing
loyalty to both the gods and the state.
Okay, did you hear that? Reinforcing
loyalty to the gods and the state.
Again, take all these themes with you as
we go forward because we're going to see
them tie back to what is really
happening. The phrase bread and circuses
was coined by the Roman poet Juvenile in
his
satires. It encapsulates the Roman
strategy of providing food or bread and
entertainment in the form of circuses
back then to keep the populace content
and
distracted from political issues.
The purpose of this was that Roman
emperors recognized that satisfying the
basic needs of the people with free
grain and providing them with regular
spectacles such as games, gladiator
combats, races, then they could pre
prevent uprisings and ensure loyalty.
That comes from Cambridge University
Press. These spectacles, they say,
created a sense of unity while pacifying
dissent, channeling the public's energy
and attention away from societal
problems or political corruption. What
we will find that will tie into what
we're going to cover further is that
these public spectacles also served as
opportunities for the state to convey
propaganda and glorify military
victories, reinforce the emperor's
authority,
um, and the rituals and narratives
embedded in the games shaped public
perception. Does this ring a bell to
anyone?
Anna ensured that the population
remained passive and
compliant. The emphasis on spectacle
over
substance distracted the populace from
engaging with deep political or
spiritual truths that comes from a paper
from the Harvard University Press
entitled politics of spectacle in
ancient Rome.
The evidence of the effectiveness of
this strategy was actually scaled up to
be Roman spectacles. The coliseum could
host tens of thousands of spectators and
the circus maximus could hold up to
250,000
people. They were experimenting. They
were practicing this then. It was a
proven and effective method and they've
carried it through history up till
today. The state invested heavily in
these events, recognizing their power to
shape and control public sentiment.
That is quite a statement, don't you
think? Now, this lands us where we're
about to go. It says uh it says asa
Catholicism expanded during the
transition from the Roman Empire to the
medieval period, the church began
incorporating pagan practices including
sports and festivals into its rituals to
maintain control over the populace and
align communal celebrations with
religious teachings. Physical discipline
through organized sports was promoted
within a moral framework to encourage
obedience and suppress independent
thought. The Jesuits further advanced
this integration by using competitive
sports in their educational institutions
all over the world to shape disciplined,
morally upright individuals and redirect
youthful energy away from subversive
ideas. During the industrial revolution,
religious schools, particularly in
Britain, formalized many modern sports,
reinforcing values of character and
discipline and laying the foundation for
globally organized competitions. With
the rise of mass media in the 20th
century, sports evolved into major
commercial spectacles that captivated
public attention and deepened emotional
investment through team rivalries. This
widespread enthusiasm mirrors the
ancient Roman tactics of bread and
circuses, using entertainment to foster
social cohesion, distract from critical
issues, and sub subtly reinforce
nationalistic or corporate ideologies.
So that comes from all over the place.
Quite a lot of Harvard and Oxford and
Cambridge quotes there. Have you ever
noticed it's not just like
commercials for you know drinks and
chips and products though that is how
they also get their propaganda out but
it's also political like they mentioned
it is religious in content a lot of the
time now with commercials
um they can add yoga in there they could
add like we've seen with the KFC
commercial so it encompasses quite a lot
already if you really think about how
many different types of propaganda are
coming at you
through their methods to reinforce
beliefs. And this comes from Angelus
Always Forward newsletter. It's not um
nothing I had ever heard of before, but
it's entitled, "Here's a look at the
NFL's Catholic roots." This writer opens
it up by saying, "My own parish priest,
a Los Angeles Rams fan, jokingly
referred to Super Bowl Sunday as a holy
day of
obligation." And that's what it feels
like for many Americans as fans prepare
to watch the Rams take on the Cincinnati
Bengals in the Super Bowl at Los Angeles
Sofi Stadium February 3rd. Catholic
viewers may not realize how much their
fellow believers have been involved in
the history and success of American
football. Here are just a few Catholics
without whom the National Football
League and the Super Bowl might not
exist. These are one of the uh extreme
fans dressed and they start talking
about Vince Lombardi. The winner of the
Super Bowl gets the Lombardi trophy
named for one of the football's one of
football's most beloved figures and a
devout son of the church. Born into a
Catholic family of Italian descent in
Brooklyn. If it's a big deal that this
guy Vince Lombardi has a trophy
um that the Super Bowl winners get, then
it's his life and his legacy is quite
significant to the Catholics and the
ties to football. Another one, Timothy
Mara, he's one of the founders, if you
look here, one of the founders of the
NFL. When he died, his eulogist kept
pointing out he was the last of the old
school sports team owners, a throwback
to football's leather helmet era. This
is actually very interesting. He also
was a book maker and a regular at the
Saratoga Racecourse in Saratoga Springs,
New York. So bookmakers of course are
those who take bets for gambling on or
betting on games. And so we will see
that that is also of course quite the
pattern. The point is that it's quite
embedded very much embedded in their
structure. It's a holy day of
obligation. It is something that they
highly recommend or suggest or advocate
for to be honest because it is so tied
with its roots in Catholicism. Here's
why it matters a little bit more. says,
"It is well known that Pope Francis in
his speech to fellow cardinals in the
general congregation to elect a new pope
recalled the passage from Revelation
where Jesus says, "Behold, I stand at
the door and knock." The image that came
to his mind, however, was not typical.
He imagined Jesus standing inside the
church at the door and knocking wanting
to get
outside into the world to be with people
where they were living their lives.
The church is taking a significant step
in this direction with the publication
of its first major document about
sports. This document attends closely to
what happens to the human person in the
context of playing sports and asks what
leads to his or her integral development
or to
diminished diminishment and desolation.
It also considers the impact of sports
on society, the pursuit of the common
good and the unity of the human family.
While the document is outwardlooking,
one of surprising features for many
readers may be the parts about play and
sport as a dimension of the cultural and
theological heritage of the church. It
is important to note that the respect to
play and sport as experienced in the
history of the church, it is a lay
people who are the principal actors. Lay
people played games and sports on feast
days. Oh, right. They're admitting it on
feast days throughout the medieval
period where the students playing sports
in the humanism in the humanist and
early Jesuit schools and later Catholic
schools and are the players and coaches
in contemporary contexts in different
parts of the world.
It is fitting then that the document is
published by
the diccasterie for ley family and life
which has responsibility for animating
and encouraging the vocation of lay
people in the church and in the world
and they claim I'll just summarize a
little bit of this that a person is a
combination of the unity of body soul
and spirit and so in education as they
say here we are bringing we're not
bringing up a soul we are not bringing
up a body. We are bringing up a person.
We must not split him into two. So they
argued in their context for um school
and education that the Catholics would
bring this argument up to include it
because you have to deal with people's
physical health as well. Um, to me that
sounds kind of like a cover up to bring
in these feasts and games that were
played on these feast days in antiquity
in ancient Rome and Greece and bring
them back onto our calendars back into
the public view without them knowing and
having them participate. This one, of
course, I am really not going to touch
on this much, but it is interesting that
they're even writing this on the History
Channel. As you can see right there, the
Olympic torch
relays surprising Nazi origins. The
ritual of the Olympic torch relay
originated not in ancient Greece but in
Nazi Germany in
1936. There's a picture. While the
pageantry appeared to reprise a sacred
ancient Greek tradition, the Olympic
torch relay was actually a piece of
modern political theater, carefully
scripted and paid for entirely by Nazi
Germany. Let's get to more of the modern
climate we are in with sports. Uh, this
might be a little bit of an older quote,
but this comes straight from Benny
Cunningham in the
NFL and he wrote this on his social
media account and then erased it. But it
he said, "The NFL is scripted, but they
make us sign something, so we can't go
into
detail." I'm tired tired of holding
back. Who wants the full story? Former
Bears RB says NFL is scripted in social
media rants. They're addressing it even
further. But here's another person
here. He agrees. Isn't this interesting?
XNFL RB Larry Johnson agrees with his
tweet.
So, you have another former
um NFL player who actually agrees and
says he said what he did. Who wants the
full story right here? That quote. And
then the article states he has since
deleted that tweet and never gave the
full story. When former teammate Tark
Cohen retweeted Cunningham and responded
with only multiple laughing emojis,
Cunningham doubled down, responding,
"Let's be real with people, bro." And
so, you do you have people seriously
coming out of the woodwork and telling
you exactly what is happening. And
that's what we're going to see even
further. There's the exact area we have
it from. The Jesuits through their
emphasis on education and holistic view
of the human person have historically
played a significant role in promoting
sports and the integration of physical
activity into education influencing the
development of sports culture and
institutions. So they're the ones who
really did drive it home for all like
they're saying all institutions, all
schools. It became a huge part. No
school operates without really a um
department that teaches sports and PE.
And we know why. Here is the first of a
few videos I'm going to show you guys.
The last game of the season. I remember
Sterling came I actually our coach came
lock. said, "You guys don't be upset,
but I've been told to take y'all out
after the first five minutes of the game
because Sterling wanted to see David
Robson keep the scoring title in the
West cuz he didn't want Shaquille O'Neal
to get the scoring title in the East." I
remember when he hit 60 or something
like 70 timeout. So that game was fixed.
And if you go back watch that game, we
didn't play and I like I'm out. They
can't off me enough. I'm I'm I'm done. I
remember that 70. I remember that being
Mark Jackson or and Ron Harper, they
tell you, "Wow." Yeah. Donald Sterling.
Wow. So, he's telling him right there
and
then that it was all planned um and how
they planned it in a way that made him
angry. Um our next clip, I'm just going
to let these kind of speak for
themselves cuz I don't really know much
about sports myself either. But,
um let's play this one.
I remember we about to play game seven
2012. So we about to play the Celtics or
whatever. I'm like, "Yeah, bro. We got a
game seven. Like we have to bam. Like
this going to be lit." So Adam's like,
"You know we going to have to win by 15
just to win by one." So I'm like, "What
you mean?" He's like, "Bro, this is the
NBA. It's entertainment. Like LeBron is
in a Heat or waiting. Would you rather
watch the Celtics or the Sixers play the
Heat? I'm going to be honest with you.
I'm on a team. I wouldn't even watch the
Sixers play the Heat." Like, so we
get in this game, you know how much
money the NBA is going to lose. I'm
telling you, take M's and M's from this.
I'm like, what? He say, millions of
memories, cuz this is entertainment. Oh,
that's a bar. And he said, as long as
you know that, don't act like your OG
ain't tell you. You have to be of so
much that don't affect it.
Interesting.
All right. I believe this man's name is
Jake Paul here. And I've been in this
sport
for a year now. And like I probably
shouldn't be saying this, but all of
this You know, you see people
whining and dininging each other. You
see people at Staple Center like who was
at the who was at the Staple Center last
night with KSI.
You know, people people the sports rings
for sure 100%.
was ranked. He said 100%.
In a short amount of time I've been
here, I've heard multiple stories about
people paying stuff off, choosing
fights, what time people sign contracts.
Okay. And
he was he in boxing, I think. Yep.
Boxing against Mike Tyson when that
happened. All
right. Here we go. Shaquille O'Neal.
All these leagues. Are your rings real?
No. Oh, so it was crypted. You knew you
was getting them? Of course. All day,
every day. So yeah, I knew you was
getting them that year. I did. Yeah.
There's a script. True story. I never
told the story. In the first round,
first championship in the first round. I
forget who we playing. I I hear Phil
Jackson tell Gary Vidy, "Hey, get us
some hotels in Indiana cuz that's who
we're going to play in the finals."
This was like before game one in the in
the finals and like it didn't hit me
until we got to Indiana. Or maybe he
just knew that they were the best team
in the East. I don't know. I I'm just
telling you what I heard the man say. We
haven't even played one game yet. They
were back in the meeting. He's like,
"Yeah, get us some, you know, hotel
rooms in Indiana. I don't want to stay
in Indiana. I want to stay on the, you
know, outsert Indiana." Are you happy
they cast you in the role of Shaquille
O'Neal? Yes. I'm very, very happy and
I'm glad we beat Reggie.
Wow.
All right. There are many more here.
They're still adding money to the
program. So, and people like, "Why are
you saying this? You used to play." I'm
like, "Yeah." I see. Me speaking about
this really goes against me. Like my my
annuities and my portfolio is in the
NFL. It's under NFL. So, if they go
down, my stuff goes down. But I feel
like you guys' souls mean more much I
mean mean much to me. So, you can see
the bigger picture. So you don't have to
argue with Wednesday at 3:00 PM with a
fan that's a Patriots fan. Y'all guys
cussing each other out. And it's not
even it it's it's
all it's it's just all scripted. Like
you want me to say it's like I can't
tell you if y'all were scripted when I
was playing it because I'm underneath
that matrix
where I'm just going running my plays.
But when you look at outside of it, you
see these these calls that are being
called don't make sense. You see the
penalties that are happening. Like some
people I want people to detach from
making NFL football their idol and
worshiping it all the time. I'm trying
to get people to pull back a little bit
and see the the bigger perspective in
life. Y'all know all the X's and O's,
man. I'm just sitting at home watching.
I I I don't like to get into that
because I don't believe the game is
really decided on the field. So, you
know, I don't get into all the X's and
O's and talking, man. I like I said, I
played in the game. Well, I set a Super
Bowl record and we knew every play that
was running before the game starts. So,
hey, who am I to say? Well, tell us
about that week leading up to the Super
Bowl because that was the big thing.
Bill Callahan was the Raiders coach at
the time. Obviously, John Gruden had
just come over. Tell us about that week
of preparation leading up to the game
and how it was executed by you guys. I
mean, you know, you could know which
plays are coming and Tim Brown and Jerry
Wright come out and say that they made
them run. Jerry Rice I mean Tom Don
Gutton's offense. Yes. Yes. It was his
offense and you guys knew exactly what
was coming. Did you know every single
play? They didn't run that they didn't
run that they didn't run that offense
all year though. Ain't it odd that you
would run it when you playing against
us? So did did you guys knew know every
play before the ball was snapped?
I'm just saying man the game ain't
decided on the field. That's all I'm
going to say.
The reason you guys won the Super Bowl
wasn't because of your outstanding
defense. It was because that's the way
it was predetermined. That's what you
Well, I mean, if our if our defense was
so outstanding, why we couldn't beat the
Saints that year? Saints beat us twice.
So, why did the the the Oakland Raiders
say we going to go in with the Saints
game plan? Cuz they had D. They ran the
ball down our throat. Why didn't they
come in and say we going to do the same
thing? All right, D. Now, no more to
call. Well, we don't know what else to
say.
We're just caught off guard a little
bit. That's little bit. Little bit. Be
honest with you. Talk about uh the fact
that the Lions made Calvin Johnson and
Barry Sanders get back money, but they
traded Matthew Stafford when he wanted
to be. Yeah. Well, hey.
Wow. All right. So, it's already
determined before they get on the field.
It's not determined on what did he say?
It's not determined on the field. It's
already determined before that. That's
interesting. All
right. This man
NBA was favoring Kobe, you know, like
like how how clear would the was the
message coming from the NBA to the refs?
It was very clear. I'll never forget
when Kobe was in a playoff series with
the Phoenix Suns and I forget who the uh
defender was, but they called him the
Kobe stopper or he referred to himself
as the Kobe stopper. and they would show
us video of games previously of plays
that fouls weren't called of this guy
holding him or defending him too
strongly and they wanted freedom of
movement because they wanted higher
scoring in these games. So they would
show you plays and say this was a foul
that was missed and these three referees
missed this play. Make sure you don't
let this happen tonight. Make sure you
call this when this happens. And that's
how they would tr program and train the
officials in the next game to have more
freedom of movement and have Kobe Bryant
uh have the ability to score more points
and and do well.
So they favored certain players as well
for a certain reason
um to move them forward while others
were held back. Virtually every team
owner gamles on on football teams. Well,
I'm saying that no fewer than 26 that's
NFL team owners have documented ties,
past and present NFL team owners have
documented business ties to either the
gambling community andor the organized
crime syndicate. I'm also saying that no
fewer than 70 NFL games have been fixed.
Now, that that's pretty uh that's pretty
rough subject. You're saying no fewer
than 70 NFL games have been fixed. You
mean the the the outcome, the point
spread? What? I'm saying the points were
shaved and thereby fixed. How does this
happen? Well, I I first got into this
about 1983. Uh uh Vincent Persani, who
is the head of the Michigan State
Attorney General's Office, Organized
Crime Division, told me, "If you're
going to do a book about the NFL, Dan,
you're going to have to get into this
guy, Don Dawson, because he was fixing
games." We knew it. I went to my friends
and my sources at the Internal Revenue
Service, the Organized Crime
Intelligence Division. They said Don
Dawson was fixing games. I went to the
FBI, the Organized Crime and
Racketeering Section of the Justice
Department, and Strikeforce field
offices. Everybody told me what Don
Dawson was fixing games. At that point,
I had enough evidence to print that
allegedly Don Dawson was fixing NFL
games. He was a major bookmaker in the
Midwest. I then went to Dawson. I
tracked him down. I jumped through all
kinds of hoops to interview him. And
when I interviewed him on about the
seventh or eighth interview, he admitted
to me that he had personally
participated in the fixing of no fewer
than 32 NFL games. How and how does that
happen? He liked to work with the
quarterback. He would he would he would
go to the the quarterback would come to
him and say, "Um, I need some bread."
uh what's the line on the game this
week? And the uh and the bookmaker would
say, you guys are favored by six points.
And then the reply was we're not going
to cover the spread. And basically that
was it. Now, do you you do you name
players? Oh, sure. I name players. And
also in 1979, I name I I I go into the
specifics of eight fixed games that were
uh allegedly fixed by two referees who
were investigated by both the FBI and
the IRS. And I named I list the uh eight
games in uh on page 308 of the book.
Yeah. The the obvious question you're
pointing you're talking about all these
games being fixed. You're talking about
all these people involved. You're
talking about going to various agencies
and they're saying who the people are
involved. Why why has this been why has
this gone uncovered? If this is the
case, what I'm also alleging in the book
is that no fewer than 50 legitimate
investigations of corruption within the
NFL have been either suppressed or just
flatout killed as a result of a
sweetheart relationship between NFL
security, which is the internal police
force within the league and a variety of
federal and state and local law
enforcement agencies. I have more I'm a
big baseball fan and I have more respect
for baseball right now because of the
way it's handled the Pete Rose case and
the open and honest manner that has
handled this case than I've ever had
before. I have more confidence in
baseball because it's handled. How do
these investigations get quashed?
Basically, it's a it's a rel the NFL
security people who are all former
Justice Department people will go to
their colleagues, their old colleagues
in the Justice Department or in these
various law enforcement agencies and
they'll say uh we um we can handle this
internally. Let us handle internally so
that we're not getting all the publicity
that we would be getting. And so to all
intents and purposes, these
investigations we be I can say chapter
invest again I said about 50 in the
book. the um it is a strange sport
because it is the one sport where you
can go to a game and come away even if
your home team has won disappointed.
Wow. So these people know that they're
all doing
that and they can I mean what I mean is
these agencies that are in the
government can tell you that this man is
actually rigging the game and everything
and they don't mind it. And most of
these people are behind him from the
Department of Justice. Incredible.
glove is stuck. Hi, I'm Coen Leler with
the Minnesota Vikings and this is the
Ultimate Reception. Now every kid can
catch like a pro. Come take a look.
Players using an ultimate reception
football and gloves are so effective
they are not allowed in any high school
or NCAA football
game. This product is strictly for youth
and athletes who want to catch like a
pro every time. Ultimate Reception
features a patent pending magnetic grip
system that literally makes the ball
stick to your
hand. And with the smallest, strongest
magnets in the world on your side, it
usually only takes one hand.
Okay, so that's proof they showed you in
the beginning of real games that had
been played with what looks like this
ball that's magnetic and the magnetic
gloves as well and how it works. All
right, here's a very significant one.
It's kind of crazy. It's Bill Cooper.
That's why they pay athletes these
fantastic salaries. I was listening to
radio the other day. They just
contracted to pay one one player on one
team $6
million a year. Can you believe this?
And why is that? It's the Roman circus.
What does the emperor do when the people
become restive and when the people are
asking questions and when the people
don't like the policies of the
emperor? He sends them to the circus. He
creates a circus. He builds a giant
coliseum and he begins to throw the
Christians to the lions and he has great
chariot races and football games and
basketball games all to keep the idiots
preoccupied with things that don't mean
anything in the scheme of the entire
world. So that they don't have the time
to learn what the truth is. So they
don't ever get smart enough to learn how
they're being
manipulated. So they don't ever question
the
emperor. That's why they pay a player on
a football team or a baseball team a
million or2 million or $3 million a
year. It is the Roman
circus. I know men who don't know
anything in the world except who plays
third base for the Mets. And they think
that's a great accomplishment. and they
meet and pat each other on the back and
bond and go have cocktails and talk
about what this guy that plays third
base for the Mets did in last night's
game. Sad. It's really sad. Is there any
room in in uh in a kind of society where
these manipulations are not taking place
for this type of entertainment or any
type of entertainment at all? If people
understand that a game is a game, if
people understand that nobody, nobody,
no matter what they do, is worth paying
two or$3 million a year
for, people should be able to get rich
if they want to. Mhm. By the sweat of
their individual labor, okay, by going
on doing something for the world. Mhm.
Not by taking people's minds away from
the
emperor. It's a game. Football is a
game.
Football's a
game. But let me tell you something.
When 150 of the most powerful men and
women in the world can meet in secret in
Bod and Boden, Germany and plot the fate
of
billions and nobody even cares about
it. But six football players go to lunch
together and it's in the headlines
across the country. You have a
reflection of the society in which that
exists and it is a sick sick society
that it's
doomed to self-destruct.
Wow, that is quite something. But he
speaks truth. This is very very true of
what what it's all founded on, why it
was founded and the very purpose
of sports directly. Now one interesting
thing I'll show you now is um I found
this that the
diamond itself is in fact Masonic
symbol. Um, if you look here real quick,
let's see if I can get that
bigger. This possibly is not where I
want to go. Oh, yes. Okay. So, you see
the square and compass and the
field. It mirrors it almost. Baseball is
an oult masonic ritual where even most
of the players aren't aware of their
actual roles in the ritual itself. nor
does the the unaware audience of the
masses watching the game or rituals from
home or at the stadium. Right? We're
going to find out why. Because when you
look at
this, this is um straight from one of
the occult websites as well. You have
the sun, the moon, uh angels in the
outfield. Interesting enough, uh this
symbol and the ball. I honestly am not
sure what all is going on here, but if
we
go backwards, perhaps we can go into
this and re I want y'all to pay
attention to this. Oops. The baseball
field represents the Freemasonry logo.
All right, so that's all they had to
say. That doesn't really help me.
All right, this website is much more
helpful. That's where it originally came
from. And it
states, "It is the vernal equinox and
the ritual has begun. The participants
enter into the sacred quadrant and take
their stations at geometrically
significant places. They are all men
dressed in pure white garb marked with
colorful esoteric symbols. They hold
ritual implements in their hands. Four
more men arrive. They are dressed in
dark blue like concealbrated priests.
Concealbrating priests. They confer on
the details of the liturgy. Then they
too take their
places.
[Music]
Um we need look no further than the
local baseball diamond to find high
ritual. There's no need to hanker after
secret masonic rights in closed halls or
occult workings in incense filled
chambers. Wherever baseball is played, a
true ritual goes on and esoteric as
esoteric as daylight as powerful as
spring. Now, yeah, I'm not going to go
through why all of this is true, but
this comes from
um the Southern Cross
Review, but you can see that it's not
just them saying it. It is several
different sources when you really look
at it. So, go look it up yourself. Um
it's not something I love baseball, but
only playing it myself and that doesn't
make it better. But I didn't even know
this. So, if you want to know more about
this, I won't be covering baseball
specifically. You can go and look that
up. And
that finally brings us to a few verses
that came to
mind around this
topic. 1 Corinthians 13:11. And it says,
"When I was a child, I spake as a child.
I understood as a child. I thought as a
child, but when I became a man, I put
away childish things. And that is what I
believe, especially what Bill Cooper was
saying is exactly that, to keep you
um distracted, to keep you
immature, to make you not develop into
an adult who understands what is going
on around you. that it's not important
to see past the distraction and be able
to then discern I don't need to have
anything to do with this distraction the
childish things they're talking
about and the second verse that I found
was 2 Corinthians 2 11 it said lest
Satan should get an advantage of us for
we are not ignorant of his
devices and this is applies ties to this
in in the way that we would perhaps
not think of. But if you really do think
of Satan's devices, you do have to
include once we know the origins and why
the Catholic Church and the Jesuits are
all in on this is to distract just like
he creates distractions and traps for
us. So, let's not be ignorant and
mature within our spiritual lives with
Christ now that we
know. I pray that we would all do this
in our lives and um that it would touch
our hearts that this is coming straight
from the players mouths, the Catholics,
the Jesuits themselves. We know
everything has been unveiled about it.
So, thank you for watching. Thank you
for being here. Um we love you guys and
thank you for all your support. Again,
please like, subscribe and share and we
will see you next time.